So let's reset.
Uh, the real story here with Trump and Ukraine
is the whistleblower complaint.
All along.
We had reports of what was believed to be
in the complaint, news of the suppression
of the complaint.
Donald Trump saying he would release a transcript,
but then releasing a summary, the Democrat
decision, uh, the Democrats a decision, I
don't want to fall into that, uh, a right
wing meme of saying Democrat, the decision
made by Democrats to, um, start an impeachment
inquiry against Donald Trump.
We had all this stuff swirling, but really
at the core, the whistleblower complaint is
the thing here.
We now have the complaint and arguably the
most stunning revelation about what's in the
report that we didn't already know, which
has now been declassified, is that the complaint
says not only was there a planned and proactive
pattern of odd few station around the phone
call between Donald Trump and the Ukrainian
president, but it specifically says that Trump
administration officials have moved records
of Donald Trump's conversations with foreign
officials, including this July 25 phone call
to a separate computer network or server.
Then where these are habitually stored.
Now the exact details we don't yet know is
it, are we talking about a private server
reminiscent of what Hillary Clinton was criticized
for doing?
Are we talking about, we don't know the exact
technical specifications of what was done,
but specifically the whistleblower says the
July 25 phone call with the Ukrainian president,
which is at issue.
Here was one of those calls that was moved
this alarmed an intelligence community inspector
to tell the white house, you've got to keep
these records and you've got to keep them
in the normal way.
And remember we were told this was why Hillary
couldn't be trusted emails on private servers
and here is Donald Trump allegedly moving
records of communications with world leaders,
particularly incriminating records to some
other computer system or some other server
farm or we don't even know exactly where it
was moved to at this point in time.
Democrats of course, even in advance of the
complaint going public who were shown the
whistleblower complaint are going crazy.
Adam shifts saying it is deeply disturbing
and deeply credible.
Congressman Mike Quigley saying it is troubling
and disturbing.
Eric Swalwell saying that it invokes other
witnesses to the disturbing conduct referencing
of course, white house lawyers, white house
officials involved in the moving of these
electronic records.
Republicans not surprisingly are saying they're
not concerned at all about the content of
the report.
Uh, and I don't think that should surprise
any of us in the same way that it should not
surprise us that they aren't going to vote
no matter what the house of representatives
fines to indict, to convict and remove Donald
Trump from the presidency.
They're just not participating in any of this
other than Justin Amash, who I guess is not
even a Republican anymore.
A understand what's going on here and he's
a Congressman, not, not a Senator.
Understand what's going on here.
The white house is moving the conversations
that it wants to hide to some other computer
system or server.
And in a sense, this may be useful to us because
we can just look at what did they move off
of the official server to help us figure out
which are the conversations that are most
damaging to Trump.
But of course the problem is are we ever going
to get access to those conversations are even
though we now know or have reason to believe
that there is another server, another computer
system, is that going to also prevent us from
getting access to the contents of that system?
Because the whole point here is they know
what they are doing.
They are moving the record of a call which
could be a recording and or the full transcript.
We know the full transcript exists.
We don't know if a recording exists but presumably
it might.
They know that it is damaging and therefore
they are moving it.
When asked for the record, when you say, Oh,
all we have on official white house computers
is this truncated bogus summary rather than
an actual transcript.
Sorry.
The whole point is to pretend nothing else
exists.
We now at least have credible reason to believe
there is a full transcript of the phone call
if not a recording.
It's more and more like the Nixon tapes.
The question is will we ever get access to
it now?
I almost wanted to delay production of the
show today because things are moving so quickly
and we did delay production somewhat.
There may be even crazier news by the time
we get today's program edited and published.
So I apologize in advance if we know even
more than what I just told you about the complaint
and the context and the moving of the electronic
records.
It's all what we know now.
I've told you it's all of course very legal
and very cool according to Donald Trump, but
as far as the whistleblower goes, once again,
I hope they are able to maintain their anonymity,
which they want.
By the time you watch this clip or listen
to today's podcast, the name and information
of the whistleblower may have gone public.
I fear for the threats that this individual
will get from Trumpists.
If their identity becomes known.
Um, it's something I wouldn't wish on my worst
enemy.
So hopefully they are able to maintain anonymity.
Let me know what you think about the contents
of the whistleblower complaint.
I'm on Twitter at D Pacman.
The show is on Twitter at David Pakman show.
I hope you will follow
both accounts and so much more to discuss
today.
Upcoming